on the mount for the minnesota twins
tonight is john gant made some relief
appearances his third start here for the
twins tonight so frank schwendale will
stand in
oh that is crushed center field way back
and you can forget it buxton gave it a
try but schwindela the first pitch tees
off and just like that the cubs
on top one nothing frank the tank number
seven
421 feet for frank schwendell and one
nothing comes three and two on wisdom
and the payoff pitch he got him strike
three and there's the change up and
wisdom is out number three but the cubs
getting one on the schwendel home run
starting pitcher for the cubs zach
davies sinker changeup cutter curveball
been better command-wise his last four
starts only four walks one in each of
those luisa rise leads off all for his
last 16. blasted to left center field
deep to the gap
and high off the wall a rise
with a double to start the ball game
and for a rise it's been a long time
coming
buxton one hit since his return and hit
was a double that's to center down for a
hit arise will rounds third and be held
there
and the ball thrown to the cutoff man
first and third nobody out for polanco
runner goes from first pitches a ball
throw to second outed second wow
ron culpa on the call guess he got him
on the leg before he got his hand in
there a real good exchange by torino's
here and the tag right guys used to go
get the ball and then bring it back but
the baseball is faster and guys wait
longer and longer and so now one away in
a minute third
looks like he'll get one here
backpedaling is hayward and trotting in
from third is a rise a sacrifice fly and
we're tied at one jumping the runners
first hayward the veteran
swinging a mess
and a strikeout sends hayward back to
the dugout to bring up alfonso rivas
rivas bats
runner goes again pitch hit to center
and buckston sprinting in making a
diving catch and centerfield not sure
there's another center fielder that
could have closed so quickly on that
short fly ball
no that's an unbelievable play every
other centerfielder in the game plays
that on a hop and you see where byron
buxton started incredible incredible
catch and duffy is now in the scoring
position with two outs in a 1-1 game
in the air left field rooker back back
some more near the wall it's off the
wall
and it squirts away from buxton shorinos
on his way to third and he's got a
triple it knocks in a run of the cubs
lead 2-1
the left-fielder rooker went back
reached up missed the ball it hit the
fence and took a funny carom straight
out toward dead center rbi triple for
robinson torinos cubs lead to one here's
andrew romine
back to the mound again with a soft flip
and safe at first the run will score
now the twins are going to look at it i
think i think
cenote got it with the bare hand before
the runner got there but romine running
hard all the way
so that we hope we'll get reversed added
clenched in his bare hand
and kept his foot on the bag and the
runner is out so a bad throw there from
gam but ceno
able to hang on to it and the twins who
have not hit the ball hard at all in the
inning have been at first and third with
nobody out two on nobody out here's
rooker
swing went too far struck him out out
number one a good time for strikeout
first one of the day for davies ben
vette is the better davies another 3-2
runner takes off from first a swing and
a miss shorinos
bluffed for a second had a chance at
ceno but instead elected to just let him
go it's a stolen base two down
back-to-back strikeouts for davies
in the year for ortega and davey's able
to pitch out of the jam zach davies he's
retired six in a row bounce the third
nice play by wisdom moving to his left
diving stop throws to first in time rob
donald son of a base hit to left quick
move to his left and a tricky in-between
hop he has set down eight in a row
as he swings and misses
and now nine in a row set down by zach
davies alfonso rivas the first baseman
leading things off
got him to chase pitch away at 93
a strikeout for the first out of the
fifth andrew romine 21 ball games with
the cubs swung on a miss romain is going
to have to hustle down as rortfed to
pick that ball up and retire room mind
at first base another three up three
down in and 10 in a row set down by john
gann so first and second nobody out for
simmons
funded caught davies to second see one
away on a poor bunt attempt by simmons
so davies is not gonna get a crack at it
the third time through the order hands
the baseball over to david ross and a
pitching change manny rodriguez coming
in he'll face luisa rise
ground ball right side picked up by
rivas to second for one role mine to
first in time double play
and rodriguez gets the cubs out of the
jam the lead-off hit for ortega here in
the six here is schwendell runner goes
and the pitch hit to right field
rounding second is the runner
kepler with the catch an on target throw
will be a double play and the twins
doubled them off ortega took off and he
was a dead ducked as soon as he rounded
second base after kepler made the catch
yeah and you gotta find the ball that's
key number one when you're doing a hit
and run you've got to see where that
ball goes
goes aboard with one out in the six so
donaldson will climb in dangerous hitter
hole for two
bouncing ball to short could be two roma
into duffy there's one over the first
bullet to a double play and that ends
the inning
twins don't score it's on to the seventh
inning eight double this season for
wisdom and now here is matt duffy duffy
in this one a single in a run scored
he's also fly to left
donaldson bobbles bobbles duffy's safe
everybody's safe first and second nobody
out he took his eye off the ball to look
to see where wisdom was and he dropped
the ball as he charged in that's gonna
be an error on josh donaldson two men on
nobody out for jason hayward now the o2
to hayward he hits a ground ball base
hit right field pass to diving arise
this will load the bags wisdom stops at
third
tyler duffy will be the new pitcher top
seven they're all loaded up and there is
nobody out
there's the first strikeout one down and
now there are quite a few more
opportunities possibilities that'll
allow you to get out of this inning
chirinos who has an rbi triple and he's
also grounded out and the 3-2 swag and a
missing down he goes
that was heated 94. duffy backs up a big
strikeout with a bigger strikeout two
away romine in from the left side and
now duffy a strike away from ending this
inning
what a job by tyler duffy
rourkevette steps on home plate
duffy comes in and strikes out three to
keep this a two to one ball game that
was vintage tyler duffy right there
comes in in a mess and strikes out three
and two down and it'll bring up the in
hammered left field
look out
oh he crushed it
into the upper jack
oh my goodness ian hat with an absolute
bomb is 17
and it's 3-1 there's some loud insurance
437 for half ties his longest homer as a
righty they're loaded up in the eighth
two singles and a walk and now it'll be
morgan coming in to face kepler
in the air
shallow right field duffy long run over
his shoulder makes the catch tagging
from third throw to the plate tag
out at the plate double play
what a job by matt duffy to cut down
luisa rise at home plate oh my goodness
matt duffy he made a great catch he
jumped up and threw to the plate and cut
down a rise who was trying to tag on the
short fly ball
into right field great play by matt
duffy twins all of a sudden are down to
their last chance
swinging and miss struck him out
cubs win roe wick
with his first save 3-1 the final
you